[Music]
[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to my first
episode of killer mini chess traps this
practical traps can not only used
effectively in shorter time control but
you can employ them in professional
tournament as a complete surprise weapon
specially below 2000 in this episode I'm
going to show you three traps and the
content are as follow
you
Londyn system is nowadays a trendy line
and it's almost a guarantee that you are
going to face in one of your game so the
trap I'm going to show you is very
effective if your opponent doesn't pay
attention in the opening stage the
opening start with default we will play
Knight to f6 and here y correspond
either way he can play Bishop to f4 or
in this game Knight to f3 happen first
and after black plays this knee ki-moon
c5
if your opponent is not familiar with
the theory then he is likely to turn out
this mistake namely Bishop to f4 well I
must say White has made an error on the
third move of the game yes you heard it
right the reason is here black is going
to capture this pawn and now what has
the only good low in this position
namely Queen captures d4 afterwards
black will get a temp of it Knight to c6
and in fact a very good game but no
often you are going to find your
opponent is going to churn out this move
routinely Knight captures d4 which in
fact happen in more than 50 feeder games
and the most highest rated person fall
into this trap is about 2,000 can you
believe this so chances of occurring in
your game is very very real
White's last move is a big blunder and
before I show you the trap I like you to
pause this video and find out a killer
punch where black and win on the spot
okay I hope you find this decisive blow
hahaha
so black ball is attacking to piece and
only way to sail this disaster is to
capture this pawn but now can you see it
yup it's very simple but affect you
Queen check and no matter however white
response black is going to win a piece
in a broad daylight just within sixth
morta game so this is one of the
wonderful mini trap exists against
London system which you definitely want
to try out in your own game
the second trap I want to show you
happens against orangutan or the
sokolsky opening with start with before
and the interesting part is the line I'm
going to show you you can use it as a
complete reputa as even though if your
opponent doesn't fall for the trap
black get a very wonderful position
black should start with defy and after
the usual move Bishop to b2 here comes
the sneaky point Quinn to d6 and black
has set the trap right here just on the
second more of the game
I have personally faced this opening few
times in my quick games and 50% of my
opponent are following to this trap here
a White has two choices whether to
support the spawn or move further if we
support the pawn with the a3 then the
simplest is you continue with ePHI and
look at the space black is gaining at
the center of the board and behind this
wonderful center he can develop his
species very easily but more often what
you are going to find is white is
routinely turn out the wrong route on
new beef I thinking that he's gaining a
space on the Queen side but after blacks
necks reply Queen to b4 and yep just
within forth mu of the game we are going
to be a pawn oh and with some accurate
play black can easily convert this into
the full point
the third high profile mini trap arises
in the French advance tradition which
happens after the following water evil a
6 d 4 d phi now white advance the pond
and grab the space in the center of the
board and accordingly black
counter-attack on the white point chain
with C Phi ok
the mainline Theory continues with C 3
supporting the center Knight to c6
Knight to f3 and black is putting as
much as pressure on the d4 pawn with
Queen to b6 white should continue with a
3 so if allowed then he will definitely
play the move before and grab the space
on the Queen side and accordingly black
needs to stop the movie 4
so c4 is one of the main line from this
position okay now it's time for the
development for the board the side so
white will continue it Knight to d2
controlling the B 3 square Bishop to d7
Bishop to e2 planning to castle on the
Queen side and now the obvious move
Knight to e7 so that night is going
towards some good squares and afterwards
black is thinking of developing the
bishop and then castle on the King side
everything looks so perfect for the
black right well that's true except
there is one problem that after black's
last move whities immediately getting
the upper hand before i'm on i like you
to pause this video and find out a
decisive move which gives why a healthy
advantage
are you ready did you find this decisive
blow boom so suddenly from nowhere White
has monthly porn and funny enough black
cannot even touch that the shop if you
continue with other moves then white
will be a clear porno
so let's see what happens if black tried
to capture this piece well afterwards
the line is pretty straightforward I
hope you find this forcing sequence
Knight to c4 attacking the Queen looking
at the d6 square and after Queen goes to
anywhere let's say Queen to c7 we have a
knight Jack King has the only space and
after that yup we get the exchange with
Knight to f7 Jack King to eat and after
Knight captures h8 if you count the
material at this point White has a rook
and a three pawn for a measly Bishop
which is a huge huge advantage
the only chance black is having is if
somehow he can trap this Knight but you
will be more amazed that that night is
coming out in a style for example g6
looks the obvious response trying to
capture this Knight
but here comes the rescue operation from
another brother yup Knight to g5 so
planning is very simple we want to play
Knight to f7 and take this night out
okay but wait what happens if you open
and continue it at 6 kicking this Knight
immediately well no issues we are going
to continue with Knight to e4 trying to
get a check-in and no matter whatever
black plays let's say Knight to a5
trying to stop the check on d6 but we
have the another check Knight to f6 Jack
and after King to d8 and Knight captured
g6 I told you that night is coming out
one more last variation what happens if
black continued with Bishop to g7 well
it's a very simple story you are going
to continue with Knight H to f7 and
after the move at six we have this check
first and once the King move our knight
can retrieve back to the f3 and after
the whole transaction it is very clear
that placket losing position on the 16th
move of the game
well that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful 3-minute raps feel
free to like subscribe and comment on
this video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care